Now in configuration design, we not only know all the components like legs, and
set, and arms, and so on. We not only know the variables for
each of the components, like size and material, and cost.
But we also know the ranges of values that any of these variables can take.
Thus the seat of a chair may have a certain weight, or length, or
depth. Here between the sides and the seat in a very simple matter in terms of
the mass of the seat as measured in grams. So 10 to 100 grams, you'll see in
minute why we're using this simple measure. So when it is brackets for
this material slot suggests that there is a range here, it will show the range
on the left [UNKNOWN]. TThe cost then will be determined by the size and
the materials. Let us suppose that this table captures the cost per gram for
certain kinds of materials. Now you can see why we're using gram as a measure
for the size of the seat. We wanted to very easily relate the size to the cost.
The material slot now can take one of these three values. This is the range of
values that can go into the material slot. Given a particular size and
a particular material, we can calculate this cost. Note that this representation
allows us to calculate the total mass of the chair and the total cost of
the chair, given the total mass and the total cost at least of the components.